over the last few years fans have
watched the Justice League and the wider
DC EU come together but that's only the
beginning of Warner's plans for worlds
of DC domination so just what is there
to look forward to in the years to come
here's a few of the most exciting DC
movies slated for release in July 2018
Warner Brothers announced that Joaquin
Phoenix had signed on to star in Joker a
standalone feature exploring the origins
of Gotham's Clown Prince of Crime from
director Todd Phillips the internet took
a moment to scratch its collective head
then voiced a fair degree of skepticism
particularly after a short teaser
surfaced showing Phoenix looking pretty
much like he normally does Al biet
wearing some Pagliacci style clown
makeup Phillips a director known mostly
for his comedy work promised a gritty
character study and a cautionary tale
which only seemed to add to the
skepticism then in April 20 19 the first
teaser trailer dropped and the skeptics
fell silent probably because their jaws
were on the floor Joker looks to be a
dark film anchored by a ferocious
performance from Phoenix it's also the
first of Warner Brothers and DC's
promised attempts to tell film maker
driven stories outside extended universe
continuity while speculation is run
rampant that this will connect to Matt
Reeves forthcoming the Batman Phillips
has insisted that his Joker is strictly
a one-shot and a unique one at that as
Phillips recently told The Hollywood
Reporter when the marketing department
asked me the other day to describe the
movie I said I can't they said at least
tell us John rrah and I thought about it
for a minute and I said it's a tragedy
Suicide Squad may have been a bit of a
mess but it at least featured a solid
take on fan favorite Harley Quinn there
are multiple projects on tap for the
character but first up is birds of prey
and the fantabulous emancipation of one
Harley Quinn which has been described as
an r-rated girl gang film in which
Harley teams up with Huntress and Black
Canary
to face off against Black Mask who is
chasing after a young Cassandra Cain it
sounds like pretty dark stuff but margot
robbie has explained that the film's
mouthful of a title was meant to reflect
the fact that it'll be a bit more
lighthearted than it might appear like
birds of prey makes it sound very
serious
and then that kind of you know that's
not like Holly adding her like hey don't
worry I'm in this too fans will be quick
to note that in the comics Kane
eventually takes up the mantle of
Batgirl although it remains to be seen
if her film incarnation will follow suit
2017 s Wonder Woman was the first DC EU
effort to be widely embraced by fans and
critics alike and its sequel Wonder
Woman 1984 will see Diana taking on new
challenges during the era of the apiece
originally scheduled for a November 2019
release the flick was pushed back to
summer 2020 to avoid competition with
Joker and placing it in the same release
slot where the first film found
blockbuster success the sequel is cast
Kristen Wiig as the heroes frequent
nemesis cheetah as well as Pedro Pascal
and an as yet unconfirmed role which
some insiders have claimed will be
Maxwell Lord who in the comics is a
villainous telepath interestingly Chris
Pine is also set to return as Steve
Trevor
despite his character meeting his end in
the first film patty Jenkins will return
to the director's chair working from a
screenplay she co-wrote with comics
legends Geoff Johns and Dave Callahan
who will also be scripting shang-chi for
Marvel Studios
while it's always seemed inevitable that
DC would find a solo movie starring the
flash the project has endured a troubled
road the character was introduced in
2016 s Batman vs Superman with Ezra
Miller in the role but since then the
Scarlet speedster standalone film has
been a revolving door of behind the
camera talents in early 2018 Warner
Brothers landed spider-man homecoming
screenwriters John Francis daley and
Jonathan Goldstein to direct the picture
which by that point had already been
announced as an adaptation of the
flashpoint storyline with Miller's WB
contract expiring in May the start took
it upon himself to craft his own version
of the flashpoint script along with
legendary comics scribe Grant Morrison
in a bid to hang on to the role it's
been reported that Warner's brass like
Miller's dark gritty script but
unfortunately not enough to reverse
course on the lighter funnier version
that daily and Goldstein are intent on
delivering this means that despite his
best efforts Miller's time as Barry
Allen is almost certainly done Warner
Brothers is likely to act fast and
recasting the part
flashpoint is still thought to be on
track for a 2020 release the fate of
stand-alone outing the Batman has been
up in the air ever since the relative
failure of Justice League at the box
office
one this is the days where mom's biggest
concerns were exploding wind-up penguins
Ben Affleck was initially on board to
reprise the role and direct but after he
relinquished the director's chair to
Matt Reeves rumors started swirling that
he was done with the cape and cowl this
has now been confirmed as Reeves has
gone public with a few details about his
film and Affleck took to Twitter to wish
the director well although the story
will focus on Bruce Wayne's early years
as a costumed crime fighter Reeves has
gone on record saying that it won't be
an adaptation of Frank Miller's year one
comic storyline he's also confirmed that
the film will indeed show a connection
to the rest of the DC EU which may or
may not have something to do with Joker
production on the Batman is slated to
begin in November 2019 Marvel fans
rejoiced when it was announced in March
2019 that James Gunn had been reinstated
by Disney as director of guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 unfortunately they're
gonna have to wait from the finish up
one other project first The Suicide
Squad which he was hired to write and
direct during his brief exile from
Marvel with a project firmly in guns
capable hands this new squad is shaping
up to be not so much as sequel as a soft
reboot of the story so we'll be seeing
some new faces when the film drops in
summer 2021 does it well we some kind of
Suicide Squad foremost among these is
Idris Elba who may be taking over the
role of Deadshot from Will Smith gun is
said to be drawing heavily from the
antihero teams Deadshot centric eighties
comics run with the mercenary serving as
a sort of mentor figure to the assembled
baddies among the other characters
rumored to be appearing our rat catcher
a former exterminator who commands
armies of rodents king shark a humanoid
shark polka-dot man who can use his
wardrobe spotty at doormats as weapons
and peacemaker a vigilante so dedicated
to peace that he'll kill sounds like a
james gunn joint through and through
Jason Momoa Sapir instance Aquaman and
2017 s Justice League who was received
well even though the movie it's
underperformed at the box office but
then a funny thing happened
James Wands Aquaman again featuring
Momoa in the role became a smash hits
raking in over a billion dollars
worldwide and becoming the
highest-grossing film in the DC EU it
didn't take long for Warner Brothers to
determine that they had a hot property
on their hands and in February 2019 it
was confirmed that a sequel is in the
works the first films Co screenwriter
David Leslie Johnson McGoldrick is
already hard at work on the script and
Juan will be returning as a producer
although it's unclear if he will direct
as for Momoa nothing is set in stone but
given his intensely charismatic
performance and wholehearted commitment
to the role it's unlikely that the
project would be moving forward if he
were not on board if nothing else Warner
Brothers is definitely taking their time
to make sure they get this one extra
rights Aquaman 2 splashes down in
theaters on December 16 2022 back in
2014
Dwayne Johnson was handed the role of
Black Adam during the first round of
casting for Shazam but his involvement
was scrapped when the filmmakers decided
on a more lighthearted approach to that
movie as producer Hyrum Garcia explained
to Collider it was also determined that
black Adam was compelling enough to
support a feature of his own Garcia said
we were just realizing that both
characters are so special that we didn't
want to compromise either of them by
cramming them both into the same movie
we're actually very deep into a script
on it right now which is coming along
really well in an Instagram post in
April 2019 doing Johnson confirmed that
due in large part to the success of
Shazam production on the flick is
expected to finally begin in 2020 Warner
Brothers hit a bit of a roadblock when
it came to meeting it's scheduled July
2020 release date for Green Lantern
Corps the film was set to feature a
script by David Goyer and Justin Rhodes
the script they prepared featured Hal
Jordan and Jon Stewart as the primary
lanterns and had been described as
lethal weapon in space which admittedly
does sound pretty awesome that script
has since been scrapped acclaimed comics
scribe Geoff Johns who made his name
riding the world of Green Lantern for
several years is now attached to rewrite
the script from page one he says it will
be very much akin to what he recently
did with DC's rebirth initiative and
that it's going to celebrate the
mythology Andrey
Bennett in a different way Justice
League may have been a resounding
disappointment but with the DCE you
having finally found its footing with
the critical and financial success of
Wonder Woman and Aquaman that doesn't
necessarily mean that another go-round
isn't in the cards
indeed the sequel could be seen as an
opportunity for Warner to make good on
the things that got wrong the first time
but the big question is will the movie
shift the focus to the more successful
DC EU movie characters you know instead
of the ones whose mothers share the same
name some obscure man director James Wan
would be a perfect fit to take on a
Justice League sequel especially now the
sack Snyder is officially out of the
picture for his part
Aquaman star Jason Momoa loves the idea
of a sequel and has theorized that Black
Manta could assemble the Legion of Doom
he told the Toronto Sun seeing all the
bad guys together and seeing us come in
would be awesome I definitely like to
come riding in on a tidal wave to whup
some ass
ride ain't over yet mom
perhaps no piece of superhero news has
rocked the movie world quite like the
rumors that actor henry cavill will be
stepping down as Superman in September
2018 news leaked that negotiations
between Cavill and Warner Brothers had
broken down over a cameo in Shazam
leading to the actor removing himself
from the role since then Warner Brothers
and cavils own rep have insisted that
cavil is still employed though the star
himself has played at coy with one
bizarre Instagram video being his only
public comment while a script for Man of
Steel 2 is confirmed to be in the works
there's no telling how this potentially
massive shake-up will affect the film's
progress after all finding the perfect
Superman is no small feat and it's hard
to imagine the studio moving forward
with this one until they land a
replacement for cavil check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the DC EU are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bells so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]